y llegó el momento de hablar de salud ya
está conmigo en el estudio más romeros a
la mar bienvenida feliz miércoles vamos
a hablar de la nutrición porque la
organización mundial de la salud recordó
que no se están cumpliendo los objetivos
objetivos marcados de una dieta
saludable marc pues así sumamos estos
también a los varios objetivos que vamos
diciendo que no 600 empleos exacto y en
este caso pues de nutrición de dietas
sanas hay un tercio de la población
mundial raúl que está afectada que tiene
afectaciones a la salud por culpa de
tener nutrición es poco sanas tener
dietas poco sanas eso puede pasar por no
tener acceso a los alimentos que hacen
falta o también por elegir o por
desconocer pues qué tipos de alimentos
se tienen que comer que hay que ingerir
esto tiene muchísimas consecuencias
sobre la salud además de tipos muy
distintos y precisamente pues para
aclarar todo esto estamos con oscar
franco él es profesor de epidemiología y
salud pública de la universidad de berna
doctor muy buenos días y buen miércoles
para usted cuéntenos hay muchas formas
imagino de mala nutrición no a qué nos
referimos cuando hablamos y cuando
usamos ese término
cuando hablamos de más nutrición nos
referimos generalmente o a exceso o
carencias o desequilibrios en la dieta
de las personas hay varios tipos tenemos
por ejemplo la desnutrición que incluye
la de más acción el retraso del
crecimiento la insuficiencia ponderal
luego tenemos los desequilibrios de
vitaminas y minerales como por ejemplo
el yodo la vitamina o el hierro tenemos
también el sobrepeso y la obesidad y
tenemos las enfermedades no
transmisibles que se han relacionado con
problemas de la alimentación en general
estamos hablando de un problema muy
serio que afecta a muchas personas si
miramos solamente a los menores de 5
años tenemos unos 50 millones de niños
que tienen en asia ción unos 150
millones de niños en el mundo que tienen
retraso de crecimiento y unos 41
millones que tienen problemas de
obesidad y sobrepeso pero si miramos en
la población adulta no más vemos que
cerca de 2 millones 1900 millones de
adultos tienen sobrepeso u obesidad
entonces estamos hablando de que la
malnutrición no es un problema que
afecta una gran cantidad de la población
mundial doctor muy buenos días para
ustedes le pregunto qué consecuencias
tiene para nuestra salud no acceder a
una dieta balanceada
tiene muchísimas consecuencias afecta
muchas enfermedades en relacionado con
problemas de la alimentación algunas de
las principales causas de mortalidad de
morbilidad en el mundo como por ejemplo
las enfermedades del corazón las
enfermedades cerebrovasculares algunos
tipos de cáncer la obesidad la diabetes
si nos enfocamos únicamente por ejemplo
ya solo mirando los niños menores de 5
años se estima que más o menos
45 por ciento de las muertes en niños
menores de 5 años se relaciona con
problemas de la nutrición entonces
estamos hablando que no solamente afecta
a una gran cantidad de gente sino que
tiene consecuencias muy severas y muy
graves de hecho no sólo en la salud en
general sino también puede llegar a
causar la muerte aquí tenemos un dato
estas dietas poco sanas y la
malnutrición pueden llegar a causar 8
millones de muertes anuales entonces no
estamos hablando de poca cosa pero como
decíamos también no afecta a todo el
mundo de la misma manera entonces como
pueden afectar las desigualdades
sociales en el poder acceder a buenas
dietas no imagino que el problema no es
el mismo para todo el mundo
así es la mayoría de las personas que
están afectadas por problemas de
malnutrición están en los países en vías
de desarrollo y dentro de estos países
en las personas con menos ventajas
sociales las personas que tienen menos
menos ingresos y es un problema no
solamente de acceso a la alimentación a
los alimentos que son buenos a poder
tener una dieta balanceada sino también
falta de educación y falta de
información que no tienen acceso para
poder saber cómo escoger estos alimentos
o cómo prepararlos o cómo combinarlos
para lograr tener esa dieta balanceada
entonces por eso es tan fundamental no
solamente tener subsidios para que las
personas puedan acceder a esos alimentos
sino también facilitar el acceso a la
información en la educación en los
colegios en las escuelas en las
comunidades para que las personas sepan
cómo escoger los alimentos y cómo
prepararlos adecuadamente doctor también
se habla muchísimo de las grasas trans
le pregunto qué son estas grasas trans y
por qué nos afectan tan negativamente a
nuestra salud
si estos son unos ácidos grasos
insaturados que se forman
industrialmente al convertir el aceite
líquido en grasa sólida y que se
hicieron populares a principios del
siglo pasado a mediados del siglo pasado
por toda esa mala fama que tenían las
grasas saturadas entonces se pensó que
es acercar a esas trans podrían
reemplazarlas y podrían ser buenas para
la salud lo que hemos visto es que son
peores porque el cuerpo no los puede
metabolizar bien se van acumulando en
las arterias y van generando anterior
esclerosis puede generar no solamente
enfermedad cardiovascular sino también
obesidad también puede causar eventos
cerebrovasculares o derrames cerebrales
entonces lo que estamos viendo es que
realmente las grasas trans son una
amenaza para la salud de la población
precisamente ayer la organización
mundial de la salud se quejaba de que
allí siguen habiendo muchos países que
no regulan este tipo de grasas trans que
no advierten también de sus
consecuencias entonces como puede ser
que haya países sabiendo los cuáles son
sus efectos sobre nuestra salud que
sigan sin regular las y porque además la
mayoría siguen estando en los países
pues considerados de bajos ingresos
es una situación compleja porque la
industria la utiliza para mejorar la
estabilidad del gusto y la duración de
los de los productos en los estantes en
los supermercados para que puedan durar
más tiempo y se puedan vender durante
más tiempo entonces también tienen unas
cuestiones prácticas que son difíciles
de cambiar y muchas veces la industria
también tiene cierto impacto en las
medidas que se toman
es importante recordar en qué alimentos
se pueden encontrar estas grasas trans
entonces cosas como por ejemplo las
papas fritas la comida rápida los
productos congelados como la pizza el
helado y también papas ya decía las
papas fritas y la margarina entonces es
esencial mirar y cambiar estos productos
o utilizar unos productos mucho más
saludables en la dieta y tratar de
evitarlos pues doctor muchas gracias por
acompañarnos un miércoles más y como
siempre con informaciones tratemos de
combatir los malos hábitos y la mala
salud y sobre todo ahorita estar muy
pendientes en diciembre que uno se
descontrola con todas las comidas